[Laughter]
[Music]
today on journey to the macrocosmos
we're gonna be doing something a little
bit different see here at micro cosmos
headquarters we've been putting in a lot
of nights and weekends to make sure you
haven't upload every Monday or
occasionally Tuesday and while some days
are for learning other days might be
better spent just looking and thus so we
can get a little bit ahead and maybe be
a little less stressed and also so you
can if you want just chill with some of
our favorite tiny beasts today's episode
is going to be just music and video
basically here are some really cool
little organisms and I'm just gonna go
by
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us as always if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and we will be back
with more regularly scheduled
programming next week
[Music]